6 14 perhaps you weren't aware but we're
here to tell you we're heading into the
4th of july weekend and to celebrate
we're highlighting some of the best
barbecue spots around the valley all
morning long boy and we've got some good
ones ron futrell joining us now from
roland smoke barbecue this is a classic
it's near the station so we've all been
a million times ron you got your
stretchy pants on i hope
yes a million times quite a few times
too many to count rolling smoke bbq a
vegas original here and lamar if you can
i'd like to open it open this up if you
can in the back show us what's smoking
in here karina litback the general
manager is joining us here too
and
oh yeah they're getting ready for some
stuff here okay
briskets
sweet ribs okay some good stuff here
[Music]
okay karina give me give me your
thoughts on unrolling smoke it has been
a local favorite here for years hasn't
it it has yeah we're very blessed to be
a part a big part of the community
we're very excited for the fourth of
july weekend we're hoping to push out
big numbers and a lot of barbecue so
we're excited to feed the people
sauce is over here come here show me
your sauces so this is our original
house sauce we make everything in-house
but this is our original one that we put
a little bit on the meat just to give it
a little garnish when we send it out but
our sweet country grill we've got a
sweet mustard base carolina vinegar for
people that like to put that on their
pulled pork um a nice variety of six
different flavors at the moment can i
take some of this home and pretend like
it's mine that i made it up myself and
change the label people wouldn't do that
would they oh not at all but you can you
can do that i won't tell anybody
okay we also got some dessert here
you're cooking up over here so a lot of
fun stuff for getting ready for
independence day oh yeah our banana
pudding um our peach cobbler is
fantastic
throughout the week we do different
specials we'll do apple cobbler if
you're dessert lover strawberry
cobbler's on the menu too yes yes okay
so you smoke it up here and you take it
you've got rick's rolling smoke downtown
and also one of flamingo in 215. so you
smoke it up fresh right well as you saw
with lamar right here and send it out to
a couple of close places in the valley
yeah so we actually rub all of our meats
here and make all of our sides homemade
and then the other location smoke on
site oh they smoke on site too so it's
nice and fresh everything is
perfect it smells great in here this
morning as we get ready for independence
day and barbecue
and having some okay i'm going to try
some stuff here and a little get some
out here that i can try some in just a
moment then we're headed to another
location our final location this morning
we got to get some for sherry and mary
jane they want some food back there is
that is that okay you have enough for
them i can make that happen
if you don't feel like cooking this
fourth of july please please come down
we've got you come on now we got it yes
and by the way we left mary jane out
last time during the donut segments so
we got mary jane we got some stuff for
her and sherry coming from rolling smoke
good barbecue here i've i've had it so
many times and i'm getting sort of full
this morning well i hope you i hope you
make room because i know you better
hopefully i'll make room okay
all right thanks let's head back to the
station i gotta hop in my car grab some
food and then
go to our final stop of the morning i
think you're gonna like this one as well
oh don't roll and smoke don't mix mine
up with everybody else's ron just make
sure you keep it straight